you think that speech is violence
uh no i think that's what that sign says
the conversation that you're having is
oppressive
um and so i am oppressing people by what
i'm doing i am i am exerting violence on
people by my speech that's what the sign
says and that's what you just said it
contributes to and the protester is
saying that's exactly what i'm doing and
she's saying that's exactly what her
sign means so that means that you a
faculty member at an american public
university paid for by taxpayer dollars
are conflating speech with violence
yes
speech can be violent what you are
saying contributes to systemic racism in
this country it means that my students
of color are pulled over and accused of
stealing a car when they did not i'm not
pulling anybody over for stealing any
cars i see many people of many different
races in this room i i they all seem to
be doing just fine i don't think i any
any of them have
felt violence because they listened to a
lecture on
on basic facts about our immigration
system